Ireland. The island takes its name
from the old Irish word [inaudible],
the name of a goddess,
a word meaning bouncing or prosperous.
The people of this island have ancient
roots to it and its history is likewise
long, rich, mysterious and
important, not only for the Irish,
but for the millions of people living
across the world whose ancestors came from
this island.
In this video,
we're going to discuss the
history of Ireland and fall,
the story of druids and Christians,
rebels and loyalists,
natives and the invaders
struggles and successes,
all of which made
Ireland what it is today.
It's likely that Ireland was first
inhabited around the year 12,500 BC by a
hunter gatherer groups.
During this time,
sea levels were lower and Ireland belonged
to continental Europe. Geographically.
By 4,000 BC,
farming had likely made its way to
the island and become commonplace.
Ireland entered the bronze age around
2000 BC being in a fortunate location for
this age as it was heavy and copper
and near Cornwall, which produced him.
The Iron Age began around 600 BC.
It is during the Iron Age that Ireland's
modern identity begins to take shape as
Celtic peoples from mainland Europe and
Britain began migrating to the island
and mixing with the indigenous population.
Prior to the arrival of the Celts,
Ireland was very sparsely
inhabited and unorganized.
The Celts would bring it on it's
path toward higher civilization.
For such main waves of Celtic
migrations would occur.
It was the Celts who had brought the
Iron Age to Ireland along with religion
that would form the basis of the
paganism of the British isles language,
which would evolve into the modern
Irish language trade connections,
the main continent and his
social structure and culture
which would dominate the
island for centuries.
The first writings of the island come
from the Greek and Roman explorers who
referred to the island under a variety
of names and made a number of reports
about the island.
Though many of these reports were
likely false and a time is fantastical.
They would last and the Roman impressions
of the island giving ancient Ireland
and the Celts in general,
a mysterious aura,
which truth be told lasts to this day.
In a way.
The first person to actually give a
fairly accurate report of the island was
Julius Caesar who called the island.
He Barnea a corruption of the
ancient Greek word for the island,
the land of the [inaudible], which
would come to mean the land of winter,
sharing a common route
with the word hibernaid.
Caesar also said that it was located to
the west of Brittania and about half its
size, one of the most accurate
descriptions of Ireland up to that point.
Those some Romans like a
Greek law considered it the
Romans would never invade
he baron Ya.
What?
They did interact primarily because of
Rome's presence on the island of Britain.
Archeological findings of Roman coins
on Ireland suggests complex interaction
and trade.
It's possible that the Romans set up
trading up posts in certain areas of
Ireland and perhaps military outposts
with the purpose of protecting his trade.
One such commodity which they
traded would've been slaves.
The Romans no doubt purchased them from
the Irish to work on the agricultural
centers of Roman Britain.
It is likely that the Irish took
part in Roman conflicts as barbarian
mercenaries, which was common in the Roman
empire, especially in the later years.
They also likely were at times Raiders
in pirates who assaulted the western
coast of or Tanya, but also settled
it. Rome would never invade.
He Beronia for two main reasons.
The first was that there wasn't a
major tactical advantage in doing so.
It was unknown territory on
the border of the known world.
It would have been very complicated
trying to subdue the island and the Romans
weren't sure what they
gain from it economically,
strategically or politically.
Accordingly,
resources and manpower were better
utilized slightly east against the pics of
modern Scotland. The moment Rome moved
troops from Britannia to Hibernia,
the pics would likely seize
the opportunity and attack.
If Rome had ruled the whole island, maybe
they would've gone to Ireland as well.
Though we'll never know though there
was interaction with the Romans.
Ireland was one of the few areas of
western Europe which was allowed primarily
to develop on its own.
During this time,
the Irish relied on small communities
of subsistence farming where kettle or
sometimes other goods like slaves
were essentially the form of currency.
In some writings it is said that one
slave girl was equal in worth to about six
cows.
They lacked major towns and cities,
but they did have early kinds
of towns and roads between them.
Even through bogs and marshes.
The island was, as I said,
divided among many different tribes
who are often at war with each other.
A main cause of warfare.
These cattle primarily disputes over
ownership and the theft of them.
The Celts introduced new power structures
to Ireland when they came and there
would have been perhaps a hundred to
200 kings across Ireland really in their
own small countries due to the land
differences in the various tribes,
four distinct regions would
form in Ireland holster,
lanster monster and conduct these
divisions dating back to ancient times.
Last to this day,
the final and most notable group of Celts
were the gales who's influenced would
eventually extend across the whole island
and even the parts of western Scotland
in the fifth century.
Their culture and identity would be
firmly rooted and permanence in Ireland.
To this day,
the Irish language calls itself gala guy
and in English the word Gaelic is still
synonymous with the people
and culture of Ireland,
though they did right using an Ogun
writing system on stones and wood,
the Irish at this time lacked books and
literature. There are pagan religion,
which was banned by Rome and
modern England thrive there.
We don't know a lot about this religion
from their perspective or much about
their home and people in this time in
general because of their lack of extensive
writing.
Much of what we know comes from the
Greeks and Romans and centuries later
Christian monks who recorded tales,
which were preserved verbally,
naturally the Romans who sought to
convince their people that they had to
conquer the Celts and the
Christians who sought to converse.
The pagans are considered the
most reliable or honest sources.
Thankfully, however important
parts of this time survived,
which along with archeology allows
us to understand them better.
The Irish Celts were animistic.
They saw spirits in the natural world
around them so that it's trees, water,
rocks, animals. Fire,
etc. And thus had a deep spiritual
connection to the natural world.
They worshiped many gods
and spirits somewhere local.
Others were coming across Celtic culture.
They believed in an other world which
could have meant many different things
though was primarily in afterlife,
a world of spirits and the dead.
Some said it existed at
the West across the sea.
Others said it ran
parallel to our own world,
sometimes the barriers between his world
and the other world or broken leading
to a number of strange events to interpret
this complex religion where the dri
known in English as a Jewish,
the druids were not only priests,
but also legal authorities, leaders,
philosophers, historians and doctors.
Oftentimes they held as much power
as the king's whom they advised.
One of the more shocking aspects of
this paganism was human sacrifice.
They'll Roman sources likely exaggerated
the amount of human sacrifice occurring
at the time it was present in Pagan
Ireland before Roman contact and likely
still continued after it.
The details of it, however,
are unclear because the Irish was somewhat
isolated from both Rome and the rest
of the world. Irish society was not
fractured when the empire began to fall.
In fact,
rather the Irish saw an opportunity in
a collapsing Roman Britain and began
raids on it. Nevertheless,
Rome's religion.
Christianity would not only outlive it,
but would spread rapidly to centuries
following its collapse with Ireland,
right in its sights.
Christianity would transform Ireland and
connect it to the rest of the world and
important ways and the man would bring it.
There was first the Romano Britain
teenager captured as a slave by the Irish
named souk. It better known by
his Christian name. Patrick.
There are a number of details
missing from Saint Patrick's life,
such as when and where exactly he was
born and while many details have been
filled in with myths, historians agree
widely that he was a real person.
Patrick was Levy born in Wales or western
England in the late fourth century at
the age of 16 he was captured by Irish
Raiders and taken back to Ireland where
he worked as an enslaved to shepherd for
six years until he escaped and returned
back to per Tanya.
During his enslavement.
He held on to something which he
formerly hadn't cared about much his home
religion, Christianity.
Upon returning home,
he joined the church studying and working
throughout France and Britain until
his piety and dedication earned him an
important assignment from the pope to
travel back to Ireland and spread
Christianity there. Patrick, of course,
had plenty of reason not to go back to
the country which had made him a slave,
but also in his eyes, plenty of reason
to do so. He knew the Irish language.
He knew how the people worked. He knew
how the religion work, and above all,
he claimed to have received a vision
from God and a dream commanding him to
return. Patrick wouldn't be the
first or only missionary to Ireland,
but it was for these reasons that
he'd likely be the most effective,
so he went forward with it.
He returned to Ireland and though
the Irish were not fond of him,
he was able to escape or talk his way
out of becoming slaves again or killed or
something of that nature. Though in
multiple incidents he came close.
The Irish particularly at kings and the
druids were not fond of Patrick coming
and stirring things up due
to the importance of religion
in his time period in
Ireland.
He was humble and generous,
which ease concerns that this was an
attempt to grab power despite opposition.
Patrick is said to have converted and
baptize thousands of people and he
ordained priest who would go on
to found a monasteries of Ireland.
He has said to a performed
a number of miracles,
most of them probably metaphorical such
as driving up the snakes of Ireland and
converting Celtic warriors
who are hundreds of years old.
He used nature which was already deeply
a part of Irish life to help the Irish
understand Christianity.
He also mitigated conversion by arguing
that the values of the Irish had a
greater place in Christianity
and converted some of
their customs and practices
into Christian ones.
One of the most notable examples of this
practice though not directly from Saint
Patrick, was turning the Pagan holiday
of saw one into the Christian holiday of
Halloween. Patrick would continue his
work in Ireland until the end of his life.
The importance of this was not only
that the Irish change religions,
it in fact sparked a revolution in Irish
society by connecting it with the rest
of Europe. As the dark ages began
to creep over Europe and event,
which you can learn about in detail
in my dark ages, documentary Ireland,
which was formerly regarded
as a backward and dark place,
actually became an area of enlightenment
and preservation of learning at a time
when only 1% of the European
population could read.
The monasteries in Ireland
worked diligently and
preserving the written works of
Europe and spreading
education and enlightenment.
They did this to such a degree that
many came from Britain and the European
mainland to study in Ireland.
Not only were these works in Latin,
but they also wrote in Irish and unusual
habit as Latin was generally preferred
to the vernacular throughout Europe.
Though gradually becoming
United under Christianity,
Arland was still not unified as a nation,
nor would it be throughout
the Middle Ages and the fifth,
sixth and seventh centuries.
However larger kingdoms
began arising on the island,
such as monster would Kannok and Meath.
However,
they were not nation
states as we have now,
nor would they really actually kingdoms
because there was a sense that the land
belongs to the tribe, not the kings. They
were really groups made up of loosely.
You netted clans, tribes and families,
which they called a two Aha plural, of to,
uh, one of the most powerful families in
Ireland at the time where the nail that
ascendance of Nile, of the nine hostages,
one of the first great kings of Ireland,
a figure of both myth and fact,
this family would dominate much of the
Norris governing the life of the Irish
were the Breton laws
are unique set of laws,
which the Irish said we're as old as the
rocks and which would seem unusual to
us as they weren't enforced
by kings or state authorities,
nor were they made by them.
They were kind of held commonly the
brands which were illegal authorities in a
sense, acted more like mediators
that are modern judges.
Laws apply to everyone and in fact,
at times the wealthier and
more powerful you were,
the more you paid for your crimes.
Early Ireland place great
emphasis on the family and tribe,
much less individualistic than the
modern west and thus the families of
criminals where sometimes liable for
certain crimes at least financially and
would have to compensate the
alienated family if found guilty.
Though these laws were very ancient,
they were effective and very organized
and they actually do not necessarily fade
into a better legal
system as we shall see.
Rather they meet the disapproval of the
English at the centers of these kingdoms
were actually the monasteries and a
society still lacking major cities.
Monasteries were not only places
of religion learning and study,
but gradually became places of
economic and political power.
The church and this time period had no
reserves about getting involved in wars
and in fact monasteries in Ireland.
We're not only responsible
for taking part in wars,
but at times directing them against
each other. Wars remained common,
all able bodied males except for the well
educated and the priests were expected
to be available to fight for the Kings
in times of war. At this time as well,
came to miss, began forming in
England, Wales and Scotland,
many of those in England where the
formations of the Anglo Saxons Group of
barbarians from northern Central Europe
who gradually began taking over the
remains of Roman Britain,
laying the foundations for what
will become eventually England.
These Anglo Saxons were along with
the pics of Scotland to the north,
still pagan.
Adding an ironic reversal of roles from
the Roman era as now Ireland was a seed
of Christianity in the British isles.
The Irish who were religiously active
throughout Europe got to work on
converting their neighbors
from the Kingdom of Doll Rita,
which spanned both Ireland and Scotland.
Irish missionaries such as
Columbia ventured into the
dark pagan wild to convert
pick fund to Christianity.
It's worth mentioning also that this
was not yet Scotland. The names.
Scotland is actually an English misnomer,
which comes from the Latin Scotty,
which actually referred to the gales and
later the gales living in Scotland and
then all of Scotland.
In other words to Scotty were Irish.
Columbia would have great success
here and would found the powerful and
important Abby on Iona.
Another important I wish figure of this
age was Colombani who's set up a number
of monasteries in Europe.
Debate exists about the
legitimacy of the term dark ages,
especially relative to the
darkness of other ages,
regardless of the darkness of this
era compared to others. However,
Ireland was one of the brightest places
to be in the first part of the early
Middle Ages in the late
18th and early 19th century.
That would be going to change as Ireland
still continued in this era and even as
much of western Europe was crawling out
of illiteracy and intellectual decline
under Charlemagne. New threats from
outside Chris and them began to close in.
The greatest threat and impediment to
the Irish were the vikings. As you know,
if you've seen my other videos
including my documentary on the Vikings,
the Vikings had a major effect on
Europe and Ireland was no exception.
They came first as Raiders,
plunderers and murderers,
but later as we shall see,
they became builders and creators.
The first attack on Ireland came in the
year seven 95 on Rathlin island near
Antrum Modern Day Northern Ireland.
The Vikings attacked the church on the
island, plundered what they could kill.
The monks burned everything and left a
trend which was consistent throughout the
Viking age.
Similar to the famous raids on Lindisfarne
just two years earlier, though,
these were not the same group of Vikings.
While Danish vikings prefer to focus
on Britain and Charlemagne's empire,
those who concentrated on Ireland where
at first likely Norwegians Ireland,
much like Britain occupied a very
unfortunate position and the Viking age.
It was an island and the vikings were
masters sailors that the vikings would
attack other notable locations that year
under the rule of Irishmen such as Iona
and inish. Marie in the late
18th and early 19th century,
viking raids on Ireland weren't constant.
They were perhaps only once or a few times
a year with some years not seeing any
viking activity at all.
Nevertheless,
the raid struck fear into
the hearts of the Irish.
The vikings could attack without warning
almost anywhere on the island from out
of nowhere.
A group of large ferocious warriors from
a strange unknown country across the
sea could descend upon your village and
you could lose your home, your family,
and your own life.
They spared no one.
There was no bargaining with them
and little means stopping them.
It took some time,
but the Irish eventually began responding
to this threat and began being the
vikings.
Around 30 years after their presence
was first felt though disrupting Irish
society. The true permanent mark on
Ireland came and the Vikings arrived.
Not the raid,
but to settle the process of a
heavier Viking presence on Ireland.
Begin at eight 37 with events centered
around a viking named [inaudible] who is
said have married a witch,
performed pagan rituals on Christian
altars and committed a number of
atrocities.
Though his existence as uncertain.
One of the first major settlements was
that of Dublin and eight 41 Dublin,
which in Irish means black pool would
serve as the most important Viking
stronghold in Ireland. What are
the most important, in fact,
and the British isles and would later
evolve into Ireland's capitol city of
Dublin,
along with Dublin.
The Vikings would also be responsible for
founding a number of other major Irish
cities such as Waterford, Limerick,
Cork, and Wexford from these bases.
Viking terror on the
British isles intensified.
This period is remembered
in Irish as Kaga Godell.
Regardless the war of the
Irish with the foreigners,
the vikings came at an ideal time as
this was when the nail and the north and
the monster Irish and itself,
we're involved in a conflict preventing
a unified resistance to them. At first,
cooperative resistance would come though,
and then eight 45 it is recorded that
the king of mead mailshake nail captured
Thor guests and drowned him.
Hey,
United Irish effort was
repelling Viking incursions,
saving Ireland from
complete North's domination.
Though Norse men continue to move into
Ireland, including now Danish Vikings,
the death of thorniest or
an equivalent great victory.
It again remains uncertain,
disrupted and organized invasion and
the round the year aid 50 as civil war
erupted between two groups of Vikings,
one side who in the Irish
called the white foreigners,
possibly Norwegians led by a viking
known as a off the white and the black
foreigners, possibly the Danish led
by Viking that the Irish called Emr,
possibly Ivonne a boneless,
the same viking who would later be one
of the leaders of the great heathen army.
The Irish were not only glad
to see this division erupt,
but also took part in it with
some like mailshake nail fighting.
What was in his eyes,
a holy war of expulsion.
Another group important in this conflict
where the high burden north or north
scales or group of people of both Irish
and Norris heritage resulting from Irish
and viking interaction and marriage.
Their existence was a sign of
Viking permanence on Ireland.
The vikings eventually ended the civil
war and announced a joint rule of Dublin
and eight 57 in the eyes of many Irish,
the vikings would now be harder to budge.
A unified resistance of the vikings was
losing ground and mailshake nail would
ultimately be unsuccessful and his efforts
and he would die of seemingly natural
causes in age 62 with Ireland divided
between various Viking and Irish kingdoms
and his kingdom becoming divided amongst
successors as these kingdoms would now
not only interact but form
alliances against each other
in certain circumstances
with their position now secured many
high Burno vikings would now focus on the
much wealthier opportunities of the
Anglo Saxon Kingdoms and eight seventies
however,
sources indicate that both Olaf and
Emr died while campaigning and Britain
leading to a less vigorous of Viking
presence in Ireland and nine oh two as a
result of this,
a group of Irish under male Finna Mick
Flanagan and Kerbal McMurray mcmurrin
routed the vikings from Dublin,
essentially ending the
first viking age in Ireland.
This victory was a short
lived as the vikings.
We returned in nine 14 reclaiming Dublin
and expanding in other parts of the
island.
Despite they return,
they would not make much effort
to control Ireland again,
still focusing on England and as a result,
their power began fading
in the early 10th century.
The Viking invasion started coming to
an end around the year nine 50 and this
date is often considered to be the
end of the Viking age in Ireland,
though not at all the end of
the north presence in Ireland,
the Norse still in Ireland, especially
the north scales as we shall see,
remained active and retained their rule
primarily in the south and east as they
had been militarily
unsuccessful in the north.
I'll be it more as kings of nations than
heads of raiding parties. Nevertheless,
this would be the beginning of a slow
process with a viking stove to assimilate
into Irish custom speak Irish follow
Irish religion and live like Irishman
around this time across
the Irish Sea in England,
the many Anglo Saxon Kingdoms
were beginning to unite
under west six becoming a
more modern kingdom of England.
Similar changes were happening
elsewhere in Europe as well,
and a movement to consolidate power
under a single ruler in Ireland was
inevitable.
Such a movement would come from the ruler
of a less powerful kingdom of monster
by a man named Brian [inaudible].
Brian was a son of the king of doll cosh
kinetic Maclaurin when his father died
in nine 51 rural pastor,
Brian's older brother,
Megaman Megaman set about trying
to become the king of all monster,
capturing a rock of Cashel,
the historic capital of the region.
This naturally invited conflict with his
Irish and Norse neighbors and in nine
76 he was murdered during the negotiation,
which was claimed be peaceful
by his rival male mood.
Brian inherited the throne and set about
trying to continue his brother's work.
Brian is described as a born warrior.
He had learned a considerable
amount about not only Irish warfare,
but also viking warfare.
As a result,
you place an emphasis
on naval superiority.
He would go to war with male mood and the
Viking came them of limerick defeating
them both and extending his authority
across monster. He would kill mail mood,
but interestingly,
his son Keon would be spared and
throughout Brian's life remained an ally.
But north of Limerick is
well wealthy and powerful.
We're allowed to live peacefully so
long as they remained loyal to Brian.
Brian then turned his ambitions
outside monster into neighboring areas,
specifically lends to Arconic and mead.
This would draw him into conflict with
mailshake nail king of mead who claim to
be the high king of Ireland.
The conflict would be long and bloody,
but by nine any six,
Brian controlled Lenstar and was proving
themselves to be militarily superior.
This essentially forced a peace
negotiation with Brian Lang,
claim of the south and check nail.
The north though piece externally had
been secured momentarily stability was
threatened on the inside as well.
Not all the kings of Ireland
were content to recognize.
Brian is hiking and rebellion in lunch
through occurred not long after this,
aided by the high burden north of Dublin
in a war ending in the year nine 99 at
the battle of Glen Mama, Brian defeated
both armies encaptured Dublin as well,
the wealthy center of the island.
Now Brian was ready to break the piece
he had made with CIC nail and he invaded
mead defeating the Kingdom and 10 oh two
now the only region which Brian had the
gain was Ulster in the northeast almost
there would not be quite so easily
obtained and the first
Brian's armies were defeated.
Much of his advanced us was left to
cooperation with the Catholic church,
which was an elite in Ireland.
Notably by recognizing their authority
and bribing them with a church on his
side,
Brian would begin seeing more success
in obtaining all star in the year 10 oh
eight by 10 11 Brian had defeated
the canal Connell of Western holster.
He was now truly high king of Ireland or
as a church called him and Perah tour.
[inaudible] meaning emperor
of the Scots or as you recall,
emperor of the gales.
It is also around this time that he
also received his surname Baru or an old
Irish bar rumor. This is related to
the modern Irish word bow, meaning cow.
He was Brian of the cattle tributes in a
society where cattle were the symbol of
wealth.
This was a great title.
Brian and the church were now seemingly
began to realize their vision,
a United Ireland under
the authority of one king,
yet there was still work to be done.
It would be more correct view Brian
not as the king of a single kingdom,
but the king on top of other kings which
ruled their own kingdoms. Furthermore,
while the Norris Gail Kingdoms like
Dublin limerick also recognize Brian as
their high king,
they were much more removed from Irish
society and still functioned to a strong
degree independently under their own law.
How Far Brian could have gone as high
king of all Ireland remains uncertain as
not long after he accomplish this,
it began to break apart discontented
kings in Lenstar and Ulster rose up in
rebellion and 10 12 and attacked mead
and later north scales specifically
Dubliners would join in on the rebellion,
which will be led by mail morta.
To make matters worse as fighting
intensified mailshake nail kink of mead
betrayed Brian,
the two sides would meet at the battle
of [inaudible] April 23rd 10 14 the
battle ended with a mix of results.
The Irish under Brian had won the
battle thus curtailing the power,
the high burden nor
significantly in event,
which is often regarded as a true and of
the cog had Godell regardless. However,
Brian was actually killed in this battle.
It's not exactly known how,
but legend states that he was decapitated
by a rogue viking named [inaudible]
who cut through Irish lions and found
Brian in his tent than age there. Ron,
probably 70 in prayer,
hopes of a United Ireland died for a
time with Brian Baru as contenders all
began struggling from the throne.
Brian's the sentence, however,
which continued to rule Munster.
This family is known as the O'brien's
and name which like the nail who became
their own Neal's would persist
throughout Irish history.
Through the modern day and
even into the 24th century,
Brian's family and Munster made efforts
to reclaim the title of hiking and his
son Duncan McBrian would claim the title,
though it was not widely recognized and
he was one of many who would be known as
a [inaudible] and Kfar Saba
hiking with opposition.
While they may considerable
gains and had notable successes,
they would be ultimately unsuccessful,
especially as soon as the
sentence turn on each other.
When Mira talk was Brian Brews,
grandson gave up his position as king
power shifted from Munster to conduct and
the O'connor family,
specifically Thurlow O'connor Turla set
about trying to win the true title of
High King, but had we control over much
of Ireland and never controlled Olster,
his son,
Rory O'connor would succeed him,
but he would face a United invasion
from lenstoler under Dermot McMorrow and
Olster under Maria Talk Mclaughlin. As a
result, your light himself with Tiernan,
Eroica, Britney, and war ensued
O'Connor and or work. We're victorious.
And an 1166 O'connor was crowned high
king and Dublin O'connor ruled as a true
high king with the political and
religious figures of our lend,
all recognizing his authority,
Dermot Mcmurray Lenstar, however,
had escaped and fled eastward with no
intention of letting this be final.
Dermot fled to England and then to France.
In search of Henry,
the second grandson and William the
conqueror, the king of the Norman Empire,
and subsequently King of England,
the Normans,
descendants of a mix of vikings in French.
We're one of the strongest
military forces in Europe,
unable to beat O'Connor on his own.
He realized foreign aid would be the
key to retaking is thrown in Leicester.
As a result of this, Dermot is often
regarded by the Irish as one of the worst,
a long line of Irishman who betray their
country for the favors of foreigners,
namely the English.
For now,
Dermot was inviting a neighbor into his
own nation with whom on Bono's to him.
Of course, the Irish would quarrel
for nearly a thousand years.
Dermot met with Henry the second,
and Henry agreed to support Dermot
and exchange for his loyalty.
Henry would not join Durant personally,
but granted him the right recruit
English soldiers and mercenaries for his
conquest. Dermot found a number
of powerful Norman allies,
including Robert Fitts,
Steven Marise, Fitzgerald,
and Richard Fitz Gilbert known as land
as we shot arc for Richard Strongbow.
Dermot offered Strongbow a very
enticing deal in exchange for his help.
He would allow him to marry his daughter
Eva and would name him his successor as
king of Lenster,
effectively transferring rural of an
Irish came them over to a Norman loyal to
another king. There was also money to
be made and land to grab in Ireland,
which Strongbow and his allies figured
would enhance their power and prestige.
Dermot did not introduce the concept of
invading Arlinda Henry the second Henry
had actually been considering it for
some time and even received support from
the church as Pope Adrian,
the fourth and Alexander the third.
We're concerned about the independent
nature of the Irish church. However,
he did provide Henry with an
opportunity that he couldn't refuse.
Dermot and Strongbow assembled an army
of Norman's Saxons and Welshman and the
Tact Wexford and 1169 those strong boasts
stayed behind for the time Dermot them
again pushing further into Ireland,
but was eventually met by O'connor
who began to feeding his forces.
The two sides met at ferns
for negotiations which were
mediated by the church.
It was agreed that Dermot could once
again become king of Lens there as long as
he continued to recognize warrior
O'connor as high king later and private.
They are said to have agreed to stop
bringing foreigners into Irish fights,
but it was too late for that strong
arrived and 1170 and took Dublin,
began to feeding O'Connor as winter
set in and the two armies seized.
Royal Connor began fearing
that he wouldn't be able
to best Strongbow in May of
1171 matters complicated.
Further, when Dermot died,
Dermot McMorrow had essentially died
before he could enjoy the rule of lunch or
for which and the eyes of his countryman.
He's sold Arland soul.
Though historically speaking,
with or without Dermot,
the Normans probably would've
come to Ireland anyway.
Dermot son tried to claim the throne
of Lens through an accordance with the
Breton laws,
but Strongbow who had married Dermot's
daughter by this point had been
guaranteed a throne and was militarily
more powerful, succeeded him.
This concerned not only the Irish,
but King Henry as well.
Henry was suspicious of strong motives,
especially given the strong most father
was an opponent who had opposed his
succession during a civil war known
as the anarchy in England. Now,
Strongbow had married into the Irish
nobility and ruled as king of Lens.
They're unsure of his loyalties.
Henry felt he had to invade Ireland.
Though at first Strongbow ignored him.
Henry was able to secure as loyalties
with only the threat of invasion.
Nevertheless,
power in Ireland still remained unsteady.
Strongbows governance was disliked by
the North Scales and the Irish kings and
the Irish church. We're
not very happy with, uh,
Norman arrival either and would
likely oppose it again violently.
So Henry decided to invade that year.
Henry invade with a
forest of around 5,000.
These soldiers were highly trained
and well armed and armored.
Many Irish King's felt
that resistance was futile,
especially as they weren't
only dealing with the English,
but a forest which had the
backing of the Vatican.
The thus began submitting to Henry
the first being Donald McCarthy,
the king of Desmond.
Gradually much of Ireland fell to
English rule with mostly on the north.
Holding out.
In 1172 Henry began encouraging English
colonization of Ireland and allowed hue
to Lacie to push in the mead. Ireland
was now a nation of four languages,
Irish Anglo, Norman, French,
Latin, and old English,
which would have a lasting effect
on the linguistics of Ireland.
The norm is began,
solidified their position in Ireland
as they had done in other regions,
including England,
a century earlier.
This along with the Catholic church
moving into Ireland and pressing forms,
intermarriage and attempts to reorganize
the country territorially and legally
by introducing feudalism and replacing
Brett and law with English law would have
a permanent effect on Ireland as well.
The English felt that they were
civilizing Ireland, much like the Romans.
The Irish weren't content with this and
though facing a stronger occupying force
would begin resistance in wars marking
the beginning of Anglo Irish conflict,
which would last for centuries.
Vo,
Rory O'connor and Henry agreed to terms
with the tree of Windsor O'connor fail
to control the other Irish kings and
Henry a times fail to control his own
Norman subjects as well.
Many were busy carving out kingdoms
and territories for themselves and 1177
Henry made his son John Dominus,
he Barney I Lord of Ireland
when he was only 10 years old.
He would of course not assumed command
of his position until he was matured and
trained,
but in 1185 at the age of 18 you left
England for Dublin much to his father's
disappointment and the
resentment of the Irish kings.
He was expected to rule
John acted like a clown.
An example of this is that
when he first encountered them,
he mocked the beer is of the Irish kings
and pulled on them when he got to work.
Ultimately he failed and the conflicts
against the Irish wouldn't pay his
soldiers and failed secure royal
authority over the English settlers there.
He left that December returning back to
England in 1199 King John unexpectedly
came to the throne. Ireland remained
divided between English and Irish rule.
Some Lens.
We're steadily English,
but others much less so and many areas
of the country still defiantly under
Irish rule,
though remembered as an insane and an
effective ruler and English history.
John did work on capitulating Ireland
considerably by reorganizing the system of
governance on the island and showing
loyalty to him. Nevertheless,
rebellion even among John's own subjects
would sprout up and it is at this time
that we see another feature of
the Anglo Irish conflict emerge.
The Irish turn to the enemy of
their enemy France. For support,
though these rebellions were unsuccessful
for as long as England would control
Ireland,
England's enemies,
specifically France and Spain would take
an interest in encouraging trouble in
Ireland. The aangeland Norman's would
continue attempting to expand into Ireland
throughout the reign of Henry the third
John's successor specifically into
regions such as conduct where high
king O'Connor had originally hailed.
This became more and more difficult
as some Anglo Norman's in Ireland were
ruling more and more independently
and others had lost interest in Arland
altogether.
Furthermore,
the Irish were adopting the technology
and tactics of the rest of Europe and
working with Scottish
mercenaries against English rule,
allowing them to refuse to pay
tribute and to raid the English Lens,
which was contributing to
a weakening Norman presence
on the island. Importantly,
and the 13th century,
the ideals of the English nobility,
which had been emphasize in reaction
to King John's tyrannical rule that
eventually led to the magna Carta
spread into Ireland as well.
This became much more evident in the
reign of Edward the first when in 1297 the
Irish parliament form.
This was not necessarily a move to
grant the English in Ireland more
independence,
but rather it wasn't attempt to ensure
English law was upheld in Ireland as well
as English culture.
In a time when the English there
were becoming worryingly Irish,
a trend which would
continue for centuries.
It was also though a move to led the
Anglo Irish deal with their own problems
because Edward had enough of his own,
namely in France and Scotland,
resistance under the leadership of
a nobleman named William Wallace was
beginning and Scotland.
Tensions between England and Scotland
were heating up and Arland would feel the
effects of this and see
opportunity within it.
Independent Ireland and Scotland were
at this time, culturally, historically,
linguistically, ethnically, etc.
Similar and with a mutual enemy,
a cooperative effort was likely to form
that we're the first died in 1307 and
was succeeded by his son Edward,
the second in Scotland a year earlier,
Robert the Bruce had become king.
The lords of Arlene's saw a potential
ally and Robert the Bruce and Bruce felt
likewise knowing that an independent
Ireland could be crucial in the feeding
England in 1315 Robert the Bruce
along with his younger brother Edward,
devise the plan and their
efforts to defeat England.
Edward would take a force of around 6,000
soldiers to help liberate Ireland and
an exchange. The Irish kings would
recognize Edward as high king.
This would open up,
but as tracking second front in the
Anglo Scottish wars and create what they
called a grand Gaelic alliance with
Robert as king of Scotland and Edward as
king of Ireland.
From there,
they could move into the aisle of men
and secure a similar arrangement in Wales
and invade their Edward landed with his
army and may of 1315 and eastern Ulster.
He was joined by Irish soldiers and began
his campaign seeing a great amount of
success against the English there and
kept pushing into English territory.
Within a year, Edward was
crowned King of Ireland. However,
it was very premature.
Unfortunately,
this war in a second front
had begun during a harsh time,
a period of fem and which lasted until
1317 affecting all of Europe with no
exception in Ireland,
where perhaps up to a quarter of the
population to come to the feminine.
Feeding the troops was a major
burden and though Robert the Bruce,
his arrival in the winter
of 1316 was encouraging.
It only increased a number of mouths to
feed and by 1317 fighting between the
two sides was slowing down as both sides
lack the ability to continue to fight.
That year,
the Irish began splitting off from
the main Scottish army into their own
movements and when Edward failed to
capture Dublin and limerick cities which
were considerably loyal to England,
the movement began to fall apart.
And later in October of 1318 Edward,
the Bruce died in battle.
Despite a technical English victory,
Ireland was becoming too
difficult to control.
This war had torn apart English authority
on the island and English power began
waning and the area over the course of
the 14th century though controlling many
parts of the island,
the English monarchy only truly held
power in the areas around Dublin.
In 1327 Edward the third
came to the throne.
He began attempting to bring order to
Ireland once again by various means,
including increasing and
administrative presence,
backed by a military presence
and executing political
rivals in Ireland while
viewing the Anglo Irish with contempt
and barring them from public offices.
The Anglo Irish protested claiming these
new reforms would bring instability to
the island,
yet the policies held,
but all the while the Irish
were constantly causing
havoc on the borders with
instability and war constant in Ireland.
The black death reached the island and
1348 exacerbating everything and killing
likely over half the population of
Ireland. The plague was most intense,
the towns and cities where English power
was concentrated and thus the native
Irish gained more power and authority.
By 1360 the situation was so desperate
that the Anglo Irish wrote to the king
informing him that if nothing was done,
Ireland will be lost.
In response,
Edwards sent his son Lionel to Ireland
with an army to restore authority
primarily to ensure Ireland's loyalty and
economic profitability during war with
France.
Lionel was not greatly successful and
many in England complained that the
resources required to hold on to Ireland
far outweighed its economic worth and
even if it were worth it,
England had more significant problems
like France and Scotland as well as these
sicknesses and feminines which cause
havoc on the nation. By this point,
the Anglo Irish becoming
now truly worryingly Irish
as they were speaking Irish
dressing like the Irish intermarrying
with them starting to fall a brand and law
and altogether living like the Irish.
As a result,
Lionel called together
the Irish parliament attic
Kilkenny and created a new set
of laws known as the statutes of cocaine
concerning the lives of the Anglo
Irish.
The intention of these laws was to bring
the Anglo Irish back to their English
roots by Bending Englishman from
speaking Irish, dressing like them,
interacting with them in various ways
such as marriage and certain kinds of
business and even bending their Irish
names, forcing them to anglicize them.
This sounds like an effective means of
bringing the island back under English
control,
but unfortunately for the English,
they retained little power over the Anglo
Irish at this point and the statutes
didn't change much outside of the Pale
and in fact it worse intentions with the
hours and selves who are now
viewed as second class citizens.
Edward died in 1377 with a situation
in Ireland worsening his 10 year old
grandson, Richard's second succeed at
him. When Richard the second came of age,
the Irish parliament again
called on the king for help,
fear and the loss of the entire island.
At first,
Richard's focus wasn't France
fighting the hundred years war,
but later in his reign he sought piece
with the French. As for Ireland, however,
he prepared an invasion to
subdue the island by force.
Ireland had become somewhat of
an embarrassment to the English.
It said that when Richard was suggested
as an heir to the throne of the holy
Roman Empire,
they basically Martha concept of him
being the savior of Europe from the Muslim
Turks that the German's needed when he
couldn't in their eyes even maintain rule
of a primitive inferior nation.
In 1394 Richard landed in Waterford
bringing with them around 8,000 soldiers.
He was the first English king to visit
Ireland and almost two centuries.
He had a great deal of success and
reinstating rural authority and try to
reorganize administration of the
island. Again, Richard success,
your wasn't gained through many battles,
but more through show of force and
diplomacy. It seems to have worked,
but when he left in 1395 orders started
to unravel again and the country turned
back to division and warfare.
When he returned and 1399 things
did not go as smoothly. In fact,
it was a completely different outcome.
This was a time when the throne of
England became much more unstable and
Richard's claim to it wasn't certain
leading to a late response to what was
going on in Ireland and poor
coordination of his campaign. The Irish,
along with some Anglo Irish,
fought back against Richard this time,
mostly through guerrilla warfare.
During this unsuccessful campaign,
Richard's rivals to the throne.
Henry Bolingbroke took control
of the throne from him,
deposing him rather easily as
he had become an unpopular king.
Bolingbroke became Henry the fourth Henry
who had kicked Richard off throne was
now not keen on leaving it
for adventures in Ireland,
nor did England really
have the funds to do so.
Leading to a continuation of the slow
loss of English power in Ireland over the
course of the 15th century as femme and
caused by poor weather and plague hit.
Yet again, English power in
Ireland retracted to the Pale.
The area around Dublin,
which was firmly loyal to England.
Anyone living beyond the Pale
was considered a foreigner,
including the Anglo Irish settlers
and in the eyes of the English savage
barbarians and the eyes of the Anglo
Irish English power was collapsing and
there's slow integration into
Irish society now hastened
as they had to fend for
themselves and the eyes of the Irish.
The foreign oppressor was retreating.
Many returned back to England.
The statutes of Kilkenny were irrelevant
and Gaelic rule was beginning to thrive
again.
As Irish king's began to rise to power
as they had in the olden days still.
However, there was no Irish
unity to expedite this process.
The Irish remained divided.
In 1413 Henry was succeeded by Henry
becoming Henry the fifth who would do
little in Ireland focusing instead on
France. When Henry died from dysentery,
his infant son Henry was succeed.
Him Becoming Henry the sixth Henry the
sixth was a weak king who was viewed as
incompetent and likely suffered from
a strong degree of mental illness.
He would lose the war in France,
and more importantly,
with loses thrown in a conflict that would
make Ireland important to the English.
Again,
the war of the roses,
which divided not only
England but Arland as well.
In 1449 Henry and his wife decided to
position Richard of York a potential
threat to thrown in Ireland.
This wasn't merely a banishment as
Richard was Earl of Ulster and had an
interest in Ireland,
but it was very much with the intention
of getting him away from England.
Nevertheless,
Richard made the most of his stay in
Ireland befriending the O'Neals and the
north as well as the
kings have lunch there.
This worried Henry as Richard was getting
the support of the Irish kings who
were potentially aid him in a conflict.
Richard left Ireland and 1450 placing
the Earl of Ormond James Butler in charge
of the post. Unfortunately
for him, however,
the Earl died in 1452 and his son
also named James a Lancastrian.
The rival faction of the Yorkist
succeeded him regardless.
Richard had the majority of
the Irish supporting him.
He had effectively done what the English
had long feared turned Ireland into a
base from which a foreign
invasion could come.
In 1453 Richard had returned to England
and took control of the throne while
Henry was in the middle of
a mental breakdown. His rule
would not last. However,
and while England came under
the rule of Henry again,
Ireland continued to recognize Richard
as king, ignoring the rule of London,
effectively making Ireland Independent.
Most of Ireland was with him,
including primarily the Geraldine's
of Munster and killed there. However,
the butlers in particular,
as I said,
we're Lancastrians this divide would
rock Ireland as it did England in 1460
Richard returned to England securing an
agreement that he would succeed Henry to
six but it didn't last
and the work continued.
Richard would die at the
battle of Wakefield and be
succeeded by his son Edward
and his efforts who would later for us,
Henry to exile in Scotland
in Ireland events,
we're culminating toward the battle
of kill town where the Geraldine's and
Butler's would face off,
but York aside,
when and the Butler's would never recover.
Ensuring Geraldine power in Ireland,
Thomas fits.
James Fitzgerald was may head of the
Irish government during this time.
Accordingly. As the Yorkist
Irish increase their wealth,
he was much more of an Irishman then
an Englishman and favorite traditional
Irish culture and law except in Dublin
where English rule was emphasized in 1466
he was removed from power
by the O'Connors, however,
and was later executed on false charges,
which caused further conflict.
Unfortunately for the Irish,
the Len Castro,
Ian's once again gained power in England
about the Irish remained Yorkist.
It would not be long before the throne
went back to the Yorkist again and Gerald
became Earl of Kildare. Gerald would
be known as Jared, more Garrett,
the great in Ireland, effectively ruling
as king in all but name under Gerald.
The war and conflict
continued in many parts.
Ireland entered a short
period of development,
trade and relative peace.
This began to change again in 1485 when
Henry tutor a Lancastrian finally ended
the war of the roses by securing throne.
He did not rule as a Len Castro
in technically rather as a tutor,
which was meant to be a house
which unified it to. However,
his physician still meant that he viewed
the Irish who had opposed him with
contempt.
Nevertheless,
he allowed Gerald to keep his position
knowing it because unnecessary and taxing
problems in Ireland if he did not.
Despite this luck,
Gerald and other Irish York is favored
a suppose it error to the York.
His throne Lambert signal
who was in reality of fake,
which Gerald probably new to replace
Henry to seventh and actually invaded
England to secure this Henry
and crushed the invasion,
but pardoned both Gerald
and Lambert and Gerald,
who indeed had the luck of the
Irish returned to his post.
Henry would later send an
army into Ireland when the
possibility of yet another
threat from a fake air came and then
1492 Gerald was temporarily removed from
office,
though he likely wasn't involved in this
plot is disloyalty in the past wasn't
enough justification.
This period saw a resurgence of conflict
with the Butler's making a grab for
power. Now the Geraldine's had
been to post this conflict,
would concern Henry who sends an army
into Ireland again and would put Sir
Edward pointings in charge
of administration to work
alongside Gerald Ehrlich
Codera who returned to power
as the English realized
he was a necessary evil in
stable.
The governing Ireland pointings would
bring an end to any concept of Irish self
rule.
During the war of the roses,
Arland had been making many
of his own decisions and laws,
but now it had to go through the approval
of the king in England and could no
longer be diversified locally.
This would begin a reversal and
England's gradual loss of Ireland until
pointings Arland had gradually
been slipping from England
ever since the time of
the Normans to the point at which it
began operating independently in all but
name.
Once again,
when Henry the seventh died in 1509
his son Henry the eighth would further
transform the relationship
between England and Ireland,
bringing the two nations closer together,
but also driving the two
peoples further apart.
Henry the eighth is remembered as one of
the most important monarchs in English
history.
Those certainly controversial.
Henry's main legacy begins with the
troubles of producing an error with his
first wife Catherine of Aragon,
Catherine fail to give Henry a male heir.
After seven children, all of them
died young except for their daughter.
Mary Henry realized Katheryn wouldn't
likely produce a male heir and thus wanted
a divorce,
which was a rare and often impossible
concept in the 16th century,
especially among the ability the pope
with pressure from the Spanish who wanted
their marriage with England and tact.
Catherine was actually the daughter
of Ferdinand and Isabella of Spain,
denied it outright and thus
Henry desperate for a male
heir joins the Protestant
reformation occurring in Europe and makes
himself the head of his own Anglican
church effectively breaking
off from the Catholic Church.
In July of 1533 Henry was
excommunicated and Catholic Europe,
namely Spain, was beginning to
view England as bitterly hostile.
Henry's church will be founded in blood
as he beheaded citizens who favored the
pope officials who questioned his
power and even some of his own wives.
Catholicism was not to be tolerated.
And with Ireland under pointings law,
Arland was expected to follow through as
well by the Irish would resist and saw
this as an opportunity for rebellion.
Rebellion would come under Thomas
Fitzgerald, Earl of Kildare,
known as silk and Thomas whose father
had been imprisoned and killed by Henry
Henry.
Plan to execute Thomas as well.
But Thomas took up arms and he declared
Henry a heretic and launched three
called a holy crusade against him.
He was met by Sir William Skellington,
who commanded a forest of
around 2,300 well equipped men.
Silken Thomas was
defeated by skipping done.
Thomas along with much of his family and
scores of his supporters were executed
by Henry shortly after the situation
in Ireland remained unresolved,
though the Pale naturally followed
in step with Henry's movements.
But Ireland outside the pail was much
less loyal and Catholicism remained firmly
rooted.
Henry's sent forces into
Ireland to attempt to bring
them more firmly under his
rule under Lord Leonard Grey.
But grey was opposed by a coalition of
Irish lords known as the Geraldine leak
orchestrated by menace. Uh, Donald,
the League managed to even pillage the
Pale but was eventually put down by Lord
grey. In 1539, Henry, as was his style,
later had lord grey executed and switch
to a tactic of negotiation with the
Irish.
He encouraged them to surrender and
swear loyalty to the crown and agree to
follow English law, customs,
and culture. In return,
he would guarantee them their
lands under English law,
grant them in English title and insure
them a place in Anglo Irish government.
This offer applied to both Anglo,
Irish and native Irish in an attempt
to bring control to the whole country.
Ahmed,
these changes to Irish
society and increase English
presence in rural Ireland.
Henry, change this title from Lord
of Ireland to King of Ireland.
This was effectively much more than a
change of title Ireland and England were
now more clearly joined under a single
monarch and the Irish Lords had a much
more clearer legal position.
Henry was eager to rural Ireland more
closely and began a process that would
begin to draw Arland closer to England
after centuries of lackluster effort in
Ireland by the English. Why would Henry
begin turning things around? Well,
from the war of the roses, you learned
the importance of controlling Ireland.
A hostile Ireland had been the base
of not only Richard of York but later
pretenders as well, and the Irish also
nearly overthrew the English monarchy.
Furthermore,
Henry knew that a religious divide would
threaten the stability and the Catholic
Ireland what opened the
door for the Catholic,
French and Spanish to use the island
against England. Despite these efforts.
However,
as I said,
Henry had little effect outside of the
pail and many Irish nobility agreed to
the surrender and regret policy as
it's called and later ignored it.
Henry died in 1547 he had laid claim to
all of Ireland and begin a process which
would link the two countries further,
but ultimately failed as many monarchs
had before him to brake control of the
whole island. It would be his
successors who achieve that.
And the next video we'll look at
the efforts of his short live son.
Henry is daughters,
Mary and Elizabeth and King James in
Ireland in a crucial period in English
history.
We'll look at how Ireland functioned
under English and eventually British rule
and it's uneasy role and the empire which
would come to dominate the world and
later its effort to break off from that
empire once and for all and become the
nation it is today.
Or rather nations as the island remains
divided for reasons we'll get into if
you enjoyed this video.
I have made others like it.
We fully cover the history of England
and the United States in a similar way,
and I've done other documentaries on
history such as the ones on the dark ages
and the vikings.
I've also done documentaries on
subjects like the history of coffee,
the science of dreams,
the Science of aliens and terraforming,
and the whole array of video is on other
subjects and at of course invite you to
come check them out on my channel to be
updated on part two as well as the keep
up with many videos like
this coming up in the future.
I invite you to subscribe to fire
of learning. Thank you for watching.